and by the way by the way real quick I
don't expect any of you to take this
advice because it's too scary but I
really hope I can inspire one of you to
do it because it's exactly how you get a
job at vaynermedia which would be a much
better place to get a job to that than
any other agency in the city hey guys so
thanks for having me class a couple
things that are running through my mind
that I want to start with first of all I
think when you start talking about
digital and social it's super important
to understand that it's really about
attention right it's not necessarily
digital or social I'm not overly
romantic or passionate about Facebook or
Instagram or Skype or YouTube to me it's
just where do I think the attention is
and where do I think that it's
overpriced and where do I think that
it's under priced and my fascination
with digital social is a lot of it is
underpriced but to be very frank a lot
of it is overpriced what was the
marketer and other people have to deal
with in big companies is they have to
measure things and put them into you
know data and reports and what I have
the luxury of is to trade on intuition
and and other cultural variables that
give me my decisions plus I'm running a
marathon while a lot of people are
running a sprint
what I mean by that class is I don't
have to pander to the short-term profit
margins that big companies and small
companies have to because I'm not
incentivized by dollars in the short
term I'm looking for the long term and
so what does that all mean it means that
I've been very passionate about being
historically correct whether that was
email or search or YouTube or Twitter or
Facebook or podcasting or you know
whatever it may be and so for me it's
very binary very black-and-white what's
a good use of my time and money and what
is not and as we send this room today
there are certain things that over-index
and certain things that under indexed so
for example digital I could love digital
but I know none of you are watching the
of pre-rolls that you get targeted by
none of you are are clicking on banner
ads none of you are carefully reading
emails none of you want spam texts in
your text you're not excited about the
ads that are being read to broken up
when you're listening to Pandora you
definitely don't like a mid-roll ad
you're watching a YouTube vlog and they
listen there's a car ad in the middle of
the show it's like super like shocking
and makes no sense so there's a ton of
terrible digital at the same token I
think everybody's going through their
feeds on Facebook and and Instagram and
and that they are grossly underpriced
for now I think a lot of you will start
to tune out feeds in a decade but for
now it's super underpriced
and that's because the biggest brands in
the world don't spend enough money in
these channels Pepsi or Toyota or BMW or
GE I just don't think they spend enough
in Facebook and Instagram and you have
to understand this
unlike other digital product properties
like vice or refinery29 where there's a
where there's a basement of costs like
there is none of that in facebook
Instagram and snapchat because they're
marketplaces right so if you go to a
publisher like Turner or CBS or BuzzFeed
there's a there's a minimum threshold
before they'll work with you because
they're running a smart business but on
Facebook all of us can write run $7
worth of ads on there right now we can
all run $7 worth of ads on there right
now and I think that's a very big deal
very important to understand because
when you understand the market the
aspects of a market and what a true
marketplace is it leads to overpriced
and under priced variables there's good
and bad deals and so things I'm spending
my time on right now our snapchats being
left for dead yet the ad product is
really under priced for people under 30
in America if you're 40 to 70 on
Facebook you're a very good target for
ads very inexpensive in my opinion you
know Instagram is incredible for culture
18 to 35 30
underpriced the ad product the
influencers on instagram are
unbelievably under priced for 18 to 35
18 to 45 and the coasts 18 to 35 15 to
35 in the middle so I'm just completely
passionate that digital if you want to
call it is the right answer for a lot of
you in this room to be marketing and
build businesses on I'm just worried
that 80% of the digital can be spent on
garbage and so I think the landmine that
you guys need to be thinking about the
landmine that you guys need to be
thinking about is is it a good deal or a
bad deal
and that's what I would spend all my
time on as a marketer and as an executor
in this environment and I think there's
a big disconnect between the best and
the worst and I think the best comes
from entrepreneurs that are you know
stuck and have good entrepreneurs
because a lot of entrepreneurs are
terrible at marketing but good
entrepreneurs that are stuck and need
every penny to work hard and I think the
worst are the biggest brands in the
world that have tons of flush money and
are just mailing it in and putting a lot
of money in bad places so that is my
thesis class Linda I'd love to answer
some questions
yeah so class long-form short form it's
a very big debate and it makes a lot of
sense to Lynne and I we're in it every
day but let me get to the punchline
there are shitty six-second vines and I
would watch a seven-hour Star Wars film
it because it's Star Wars I would say
that the length is far less a variable
that people make it out to be because we
need to talk more about the quality we
need to talk more about the quality of
the khat content in the context of the
platform so in an ideal world you know
we would make incredible content that's
a minute a minute it's a great context
right you know great little [ __ ] but I
don't I love three minute videos if they
keep your attention
I love six second videos if they could
get the
point across it's a variable but it's
been very overstated in debating the
length to me it's the cop to me it's the
context of the content to the audience
that it's targeting
I love it thank you for that literally
being known as cleanest bones by you 2
is greater than being on the cover of
Entrepreneur Magazine so thank you bro
so let's define transparency because
people throw it around in a lot of ways
how do you define what what are you
what's the rub what do you think the rub
is what do you focus on look I think I
think that on the surface everybody in
this class is gonna be like yay
transparency right I think in real life
everybody in this classroom would be
devastated on how much they don't give a
[ __ ] about transparency like like it's
humans are very funny right
we talk about things they let me give an
example everybody loves to talk about
the environment in this class everybody
in this class right now when I talk
about oil companies would be like boom
right the sweater that you're wearing
right now bro which is which is super
fashionable good job it's not even that
you want to hear something pretty
interesting that company is doing a ton
worse to the environment textiles is
destroying our environment do you think
do you think everybody in this room
wants to give up their Yeezys and their
Supremes so I let me tell you what I
think I think that 90% of the stuff we
talk about doesn't match our actions
right so I don't I think transparency is
super important for upside not downside
I think what it's what which good put
hashtag add is it gets the benefit I
think that nobody you have to do real
[ __ ] research to figure out the
Microsoft I think I think the NBA jersey
in 16 years could look like a soccer
jersey I think I think I think it's
gonna be a game of some sports we'll go
with the the Walmart model and some
sports we'll go with the kind of car D a
mile model right like I could see the
NFL doing one logo like the NBA right
now
and I can see the NBA going with six
logos and baseball being too
in hockey being one and you know and
then we also have to figure out in 20
years you know eSports and MMA and
things of that you know the big four I
mean hockey's not a big four right you
know and so and so and how does it play
out like baseball took all the
short-term money by creating BAM none of
you can find a YouTube video or
Instagram about baseball that's gonna
play out in 20 years right and and has
football hit its apex because of
politics and concussions so you know
[ __ ] the big four might be eSports you
know soccer MMA and you know and
basketball and like then this
conversation goes into a whole different
place because the other three have fresh
slates and it was really only about the
NBA which is ironically weirdly
intriguingly the one that's starting
with it right for the interview itself I
would tell you the number one thing you
should do is be disproportionately
honest I think the biggest mistake that
people make in interviews is they play a
part like none of you and I mean none of
you are actually gonna act normal in any
of these interviews let me tell you why
I'd rather you not get any jobs right
than to have to keep up that facade
inside that place it's kind of like die
by your sword right like be you like be
you and be like I don't underst
like look and I'm giving you advice that
I've taken it been front-row seat to
this a lot more people are comfortable
with the things I'm saying today than
they were six years ago right and a hell
of a lot more gonna be comfortable in
six years right so when you're in these
interviews when people start asking you
questions I don't know
I don't care or I think that's
ridiculous our answer is none of the
three none of you guys are gonna say and
I think they're the actual right answers
that can start your career off in an
incredible way okay
and by the way by the way real quick I
don't expect any of you to take this
advice because it's too scary but I
really hope I can inspire one of you to
do it because it's exactly how you get a
job at vaynermedia which would be a much
better place to get a job to that than
any other agency in a city and that's
exactly right guys like you may get
lucky and get somebody who is like like
why am I doing this I get asked by all
my clients to do it it's because she's
an outlier right for the right reasons
and so you could go into where she is or
you can come to an entrepreneurial place
where like I am but like but it's just
you just want to die on your sword right
like do not you're gonna give them
answers that you think they want to hear
so when they bring up something that you
don't believe in but you learned it in
this class you're gonna answer with the
class notes and that's a mistake you
need to go with what you believe now you
may not know you yeah don't just blindly
believe that snapchats awesome but like
if you believe something you have to die
on that sword I definitely believe that
to be the case and I also and what I
think is more interesting is I have all
the advantages because of hot ones and
Instagram and all the things I'm and
they don't believe everything I'm saying
either and that's the point right let
them like they should die on their sword
not if I if I've got a moment in time
right now where I'm cool and then
blindly parrot what I say they need to
you know what I mean or they respect the
system or your history like they just
need to form their own opinions and
answer on those opinions you're really
great at forecasting kind of what the
next big big thing is
in the marketing world and you express
augmented reality to be one of those
things so I was just wondering if you
see any current leaders right now in
augmented reality and what we karma uh
it's it's a Facebook and snapchat world
when it comes to AR right the only thing
I see that's interesting in AR is the
way that they're playing with filters
and kind of those kind of things like
you know the fact that matter is
everybody in this room is gonna really
like when AR is really good you know
like like imagine you literally can take
thirty five minutes because software is
that good just to post an Instagram post
of you dancing with your sixth-grade boy
friend because you really took a photo
of him we're able to like manipulate it
like the level of creativity that AR is
going to allow us is gonna be so
remarkable but the leaders are Facebook
and snapchat because of what they've
been buying up the startups they've been
buying up and then you've got a look at
Apple and Google because they own the
phones right and so if they make a
default when we take a photo well that's
an interesting arbitrage right so you
don't need an app it's just part of the
phone so I think it's gonna happen in
mobile I think long term it's gonna
happen in contact lenses I think you
especially how young you are will live a
life where your brain will control your
contact lens in essence your brain will
control your new eye and you will switch
from real life
augmented reality uh and to virtual
reality a mixed reality world where you
can have the choice you know like how
awesome would it be in this class when
there's a little bit boring for you to
switch something and and what you're
actually doing is living in a virtual
reality world and so I think that's cool
I don't think they're going and I think
I mean I think you want to talk about
radical transparency I'm so happy for
you and hung the other women in this
class that in seven years we're gonna
know that you might be live-streaming
right now through your contact lenses
my macho I mean it I have a funny
feeling that's gonna have one of the
great impacts on our society just going
or someone who gonna start up this is
more than some of the other ones or
starting your own startup and starting
your own company uh 100% predicated on
the person's ability to be self-aware
and understand who they are if you're an
entrepreneur start a company and fail if
you're not the first one was that the
third to last one or the last one not
even remotely close to as hot as the
third to last but the one I know they go
by that scoring system right and as
somebody grew up in the wine business
where you know a wine could get 95
points 92 points I promise you that they
miss rated those last three wings there
was I loved seven the one right before
the insanity one the intellect dude you
guys need the really question how hard
core you are about hot ones I appreciate
it thank you guys oh it's really good
Linda you're gonna like it and
credibility reach amplification and I
think Bainer has a really
point of view on how to leverage tums
yep so class um I think it's one of them
so I think about inefficiencies
Facebook's inefficient because Pepsi
Diageo BMW should be spending more there
which means it's cheaper got it
very simple humans are the most
inefficient thing in the world
so influencers are super interesting to
me for example some people think they
should get $5,000 a post because they
bought a ton of [ __ ] fans on
Instagram right Ludacris meanwhile on
the flip side an alpha mom right in
that's in the highest it's a woman in
Short Hills New Jersey that is the alpha
mom that affects 400 other women of high
income around products and services may
want $100 for a post on Instagram and
it's worth ten thousand 50 thousand got
it so we had banner treated like media
like so for example if I was if I was
whose becoming culturally irrelevant I
would buy 78,000 people on Instagram not
three personalities
I don't think about influencers like
endorsements right or spokespeople
I think about influencers as in buying
media right scale and buy 78,000 people
in efficiently I think it's an
incredible opportunity especially for
the people in here that are starting
startups you can hit real pay dirt with
influencers it's more about no no no no
I would love to Kim Kardashian if she's
willing to be underpriced and she fits
my brand got it so I'll I think there's
cachet in both right again the number
one PTA mom in st. Louis is the number
one [ __ ] PTA mom to those 700 people
so I think the cachet is contextualized
right like for example you guys like the
thought that a 42 year old businessman
would have been cool to people in their
20s five years ago is laughable right
but I figured out how to contextualize
myself to make myself relevant to you
guys right Wow that wasn't me
manipulating it was riding the wave of
entrepreneurship being put on a pedestal
and then I got lucky because I was I
grew up in an environment that was a
little bit more urban I was a shitty
student I had some level of swag that
made it off entick for me to go on hot
ones and be able to talk about post
Malone or cardi B or lil zan you know
what I mean what your brand is trying to
do
you get the right reach to that point
class I think the Super Bowl is the
number one deal in marketing right
that's not digital that's a TV
commercial that I like to [ __ ] on all
the time but I think it's the best deal
because everybody sees it whether you
see it on YouTube or you watch it all of
you at your young youth will watch the
Super Bowl ads forget about you being in
marketing class four years ago six years
ago when you're in high school and
junior and I you still saw the Super
Bowl ads that's incredible penetration
and awareness you know I think that they
should run Super Bowl right but we don't
we don't plan their media we do they're
creative and so that is against my
strategy now just so you guys know for
all the coolness that's going on my life
I don't think I'm right about everything
but I really really really do believe
I'm very passionate about our strategy
of you
hey [ __ ] everybody keep going I said
stay out the way bug everybody